he rushes his Achilles tendon then he
says to me so I reached back there and
try to pull it back down I said now it
doesn't really work that way he said you
go see I know he goes you know I've been
trying to walk on my hill to see if I
could run on my heel and see if I could
play that way he said that it don't work
that way either
he goes well can we go on the back and
maybe you could tape it up I could
finish the game I said it doesn't work
that way either so I'll let you you know
shoot the free throws I said but it's up
to you
if you want to shoot I'm shooting them
okay and I've talked to him to this day
pretty much it was a shot at Paul Pierce
well he will was he wheelchairs off the
court so that was the message that he
was sending to everybody in in league
and and it was sent loud and clear